if it was why i was quitting i would
have not come back this year i really
did think about not coming back because
it did
you know i mean it was devastating ellen
degeneres is opening up about her
decision to end the ellen degeneres show
in 2022 i'll walk away really when i
when i stop having fun just one day
after news broke that the show's 19th
season would be its last
the 63 year old tv host sat down with
savannah
guthrie on the today show to open up
about her decision to walk away
if i'm having fun and no one's watching
i don't care
but if i'm if i'm not having fun and
everyone's watching
then i should walk away news of ellen's
departure comes
less than a year after former employees
of the daytime talk show
called it out in a buzzfeed news expose
for allegedly having a quote
toxic work environment which prompted
production to go on hiatus
and launched an internal investigation
on wednesday a source told et that while
the allegations made against ellen were
tough
she continued with the talk show because
she wanted to honor her commitment
and her staff through the end of her
contract
and on thursday the tv personality told
savannah that the allegations were not
the reason for ending the show
if it was why i was quitting i would
have not come back this year
i really did think about not coming back
because it did
you know i mean it was devastating i am
a kind person i am a person who likes to
make people happy
ellen also recalled a conversation she
had at the time with her wife
portia de rossi i just kept saying to to
portia i was like
if if i was a fan of somebody and even
though if i loved them i would think
there must be some truth to it because
it's not stopping and even though she
chose to return to the show amid the
allegations
ellen said the whole thing had a big
impact on her
no i'm not bulletproof and no i don't
have a thick skin i mean i'm
i'm extremely sensitive you know
to the point of it's it's you know not
healthy how sensitive i am
when something is coming back at me that
i know is not true
um i guess i could take one or two of
those shots
but four months in a row took a toll on
me the comedian also noted that she
didn't even really understand the
controversy she found herself in
it was too orchestrated it was too
coordinated and you know people get
picked on but for four months straight
for me and then for
you know for me to read in the press
about a toxic work environment when
when all i've ever heard from every
guest that comes on the show is what a
happy atmosphere this is and how what a
happy place it is
as for the claims against her ellen said
she had no idea there were problems
behind the scenes
i don't know how i could have known when
there's 255 employees here
and there are a lot of different
buildings unless i literally you know
stayed here
you know until the last person goes home
at night it is my name
on the show so clearly it affects me and
i have to
be the one to stand up and say this
can't be tolerated but i do wish
somebody would have come to me and said
hey something's going on that you should
know about she also noted that the whole
thing brought back memories of when her
sitcom
ellen was canceled after she came out as
gay in 1997.
i'm gay
my therapist is like you know very few
people go through
such huge public humiliation twice in a
lifetime
she's like making me aware that i am
you know supposed to experience this for
a bigger reason
how can i be an example of strength and
perseverance
and power if i give up and run away
and so it really is
one of the reasons i came back i worked
really hard on myself
but ellen says she's still proud of what
they've achieved with the show
i'm proud of the kind of show we do i'm
proud that we are funny
i'm proud that we are helpful to people
and that we represent
acts of kindness
and highlighting people that we want to
say
look at this person doing good
you